oh merde
j'arrive trop tard si c'est pour la
vénus à la fourrure et sont tous partis
ya une demi heure nous allons programmer
d'autres auditions sur le feu je suis là
ça mérite pas de revenir demain
j'émets un costume laissez moi juste
montrer comment il va s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît allez oui merci non non
quand vous voulez vous trouver assez
sexiste et le tout puissant le fera pas
et le livre aoma d'une femme
je ne fais que citer le roman de sacher
masoch et ça c'est pas du titien ça mon
coco c'est du porno sado maso
[Musique]
pour moi c'est une pièce sur deux
personnes qui sont unis à jamais
[Musique]
leur coeur sont menottés dans notre
communauté dans la perversion menotté
dans la passion sa passion à lui c'est
chimique sa rencontre de toute personne
qui met le feu aux poudres
[Musique]
mais tout ça c'est lutte des sexes et
lutte des classes
vandal quelqu'un d'adorable d'innocents
qui tombe par hasard sur un gros pervers
au complet par govou n'est rien
comment vous pouvez jouer aussi bien van
dyke kohn à son sujet à ce point au
sujet du reste pulte homes comédienne à
la con kaunas